boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on
super excited to be talking about
hacking the American mind sugar
processed food lack of sleep drugs
technology the attention economy there
are so many variables that are going
into this and we have the man dr. Robert
Lustig with us thanks for having me on I
really appreciate you come back to the
show you bet super pumped Robert Lustig
is a pediatric endocrinologist he is a
professor emeritus at UCSF he is also
the author of hacking the American mind
links in the bio go and check it out his
website links and the BIOS Twitter's in
the body you can go and check him out in
more detail chief science officer at eat
real there is so much going on on our
planet today and I'm excited to talk
about this with you because you actually
had a viral video sugar the bitter truth
million eight million I do not
understand yeah I do understand I don't
profound it's profound you everyone
should check out Roberts video on it was
UCSF TV hosted the video you see TV
right back in 2009 and for reasons that
are unclear to me people keep watching
it
we have more data now I mean yeah
there's lots more to know than what was
there you know nine years ago I think
one of the things that you said in there
that just people didn't really get was
the amount of sugar that we drink not
just drink eat too I mean drink is bad
drink is bad that's 37 percent of our
added sugar consumption but in fact most
of it is in foods you didn't know had it
49 percent of your a de jure consumption
is in foods you didn't know had sugar
like tomato sauce barbecue sauce salad
dressing hamburger buns hamburger meat
you know the that is enormous so even if
you got rid of soda which I think would
be a good idea even if you got rid of
soda we'd still be double above our
limit in terms of our ability to
metabolize it yeah even it's so
interesting even getting rid of soda we
would still have so much added sugar and
all these other foods you also had this
crazy so now you've had you know you
went on and you did another video
recently about a year ago on when you
published the book and you then you
started breaking down how much money the
food companies make and how much it
costs us for how healthcare for all of
these diseases these metabolic processes
that are cardiovascular disease type 2
diabetes fatty liver disease cancer
dementia absolutely so the the point is
we have all of these diseases and we
have a healthcare crisis and we have a
social security crisis if you look at
how much money the food industry makes
selling us this crap and you look at the
amount of money we spend taking care of
the diseases that they caused cleaning
up their crap we spend triple what they
make that is unsustainable and it's the
reason that Medicare and Social Security
are both going broke and I'll be very
honest with you I'm going to be 72 in
the year 2026 and I want my friggin
Medicare and you should too yeah and it
won't be there for me and I won't be
there for you and it won't be there for
your entire audience unless we solve
this problem people think oh there's a
pill for that
you know like there's an app for that
there's a pill for that there is no pill
for this so there are pills that treat
individual symptoms of the problem so
you can take statins for high LDL you
can take any hypertensives for high
blood pressure
you can take metformin for insulin
resistance you can take different pills
for different symptoms but you cannot
reverse the metabolic problem underneath
and until you do you're gonna die just
the same you cannot fix healthcare until
you fix health you can't fix health
until you fix diet and you can't fix
diet until you know no what the hell is
wrong and we for the last 50 years have
been told one thing and it turns out
it's the exact opposite the the health
and diet to be fixed it had it also you
know this not only has to come from
oneself with exercise and understanding
the truth about reality and the truth
about prob out healthy eating but also
this has to do with the business plans
and economic models of the food
companies addicting us to processed
foods to put sugars and and that and
then this also has to do with our habits
with technology as well right and if we
can free our if we can free our
communities from the those overwhelming
economic pressures and forces that drive
the attention calming that drive process
food addiction and if we can come back
to the cooking your four C's right yeah
well we'll do all of them give all of
those old others point I make in the
book is that we currently today have
four separate public crises we have a
health care crisis we have a social
security crisis we have an addiction
crisis we have a depression crisis the
point that I try to make in the book is
that these are actually four
manifestations of the same crisis that
no one's talking about that belies all
of these others and they these are not
separate phenomena but in fact all
downstream of something much bigger
overlap them they all overlap Graham and
it's also is that the pleasure
that's the blight they're in the center
right and that crisis is the inability
of our society
to differentiate these two positive
emotions yeah pleasure and happiness now
they're both positive emotions they both
feel good why should we care
so first let's define them you know so
people know what we're talking about the
short definition of pleasure is this
feels good I want more the definition of
happiness is this feels good I don't
want or need anymore
the difference between reward and
contentment pleasure and happiness and
as you even went and said dopamine and
serotonin
well we're get we're going there so
there are actually seven different
phenomenon seven different different
distinctions between these two words
pleasure and happiness pleasure is
short-lived happiness is long lived
pleasure is visceral you feel in your
body happiness is ethereal you feel it
above the neck pleasure is taking
happiness is giving pleasure is
experienced alone happiness is usually
experienced in social groups pleasure
can be achieved with substances
happiness cannot be achieved with
substances the extremes of pleasure
whether it be substances or behaviors so
substances like cocaine heroin nicotine
alcohol sugar or behaviors shopping
gambling social media video gaming
pornography in the extreme every single
one of those leads to addiction there's
an a holic after every one of those
shopaholic sexaholic alcoholic the
alcoholic you know etc but there's no
such thing as being addicted to too much
happiness yeah and finally pleasures
dopamine happiness is serotonin
contentment holic Zen a holic can you
you try that that you when I'm at those
10-day meditation retreats yeah there
it's a it's a holic - what is the what
is could potentially be the mo
profound feeling that humans can achieve
and it's very interesting how all of
these Alec's that you list all the
pleasure-seeking things in the world
they also wait first of all the way they
hit the endocrine system which is crazy
interesting which you've been studying
for decades yeah that's crazy because
the end the endocrine system hormonal e
brings us to homeostasis or not or not
or not yeah and so then there's that and
then there's also not only the way that
our bodies are and our endocrine systems
work with the pleasures but also the way
that the economics of these processing
companies and the gambling and the
shopping and the attention of Kannamma
'kz all roll into this it is a crisis of
first principles that we have to teach
our kids moving forward well indeed the
fact the matter is this is not by
accident this entire 50 year you know by
this and you'll be happy mode that we
are all in right now didn't come about
out of a vacuum okay this was planned
this was orchestrated with Congress's
help and the Supreme Court's decisions
there is a very clear not just paper
trail but in fact legal trail that has
led us to this what I would consider
precipice that we currently find
ourselves you know just about to fling
ourselves over into the abyss there's
money that's being slid under the table
for those causes that are causing the
cancer in our society is [ __ ] for
these for the greediness of certain
individuals Ron can we go to them let's
go to marketing versus propaganda here
would be really good or we have that
slide and you can tell us short the
difference
sure so we now know the difference
between pleasure and happiness
at least cursorily have many examples of
it the second question that we have to
answer is what is the difference between
marketing and propaganda a lot of people
would say nothing there's a very
distinct difference between the two
marketing is using information to
espouse your point of view true
information information propaganda is
using disinformation to espouse your
point of view so the difference is the
truth but there's a commonality between
both of them dopamine mmm both of them
generate a dopamine response yeah that's
right okay and that's exactly what
propagandists do to hook you they very
specifically play on this
neuroscientific flaw that you can't
distinguish marketing from propaganda
and if you can't distinguish between
pleasure and happiness on top of that
then we're screwed yeah and here we are
yeah yeah that's exactly right so you
put those two together and you get a
toxic mix of angst misery and avarice
that you know the world has never seen
you gave us these numbers as well I'm so
happy that you were one of the panelists
at our social media attention economy
event three times increase in youth
suicides in the United States four point
four percent of people across the world
have been diagnosed with depression yep
and what was the rate in the US was it
fifteen percent or something oh here we
have well it's an eighteen point five
percent increase in the last ten years
Wow yeah yeah and triple in children in
terms of outpatient visits with suicidal
ideation so when you think about the
number of people on antidepressants
yeah it's enormous I don't give you a
perfectly rational explanation for
what's going on in the world today we
have seven states that have legalized
marijuana California being one of them
why why now
very simple marijuana is an anti-anxiety
agent so is Prozac so what we've done is
we've traded and under the counter
you know prescription medication that
you couldn't control for an
over-the-counter medication that you can
control
but ultimately the Alisha lis the
alleviation of anxiety is that the root
of both of these and as marijuana sales
have gone up antidepressant SSRI
prescriptions have gone down
proportionately in all seven states
similar to when we had Steve DeAngelo on
the show one of the world's leading
cannabis activists alcohol sales have
went down abuse and violence went down
people have been able to work out their
disputes better amongst families amongst
and these things are leading to be good
in in in many ways at least we have
something that is going right look I'm
not here to say that marijuana is a good
idea bad idea that's not my issue I
ultimately alleviation of anxiety is a
very good idea the question is where's
the anxiety coming from from the first
principles yeah that's that's you always
have to work upstream you cannot solve
problems downstream yeah yeah yeah okay
you have to find the problem yeah okay
like I say in the book you find a wasp
in your attic are you gonna kill the
wasp or are you gonna find the wasp nest
nest yeah yeah that's right that's right
that's a really good way to put it wrong
can you pull up that graphic that has
all the brands on it the conglomeration
of brands yeah oh [ __ ] ridiculous yeah
now I will make one Balter Asian this is
this slide is about three years old
right now and I want to actually do a
call-out to Procter & Gamble they have
divested themselves of processed food oh
they did that was one of the ones that I
saw in here that's what I was thinking
there is some good that comes from it's
like nice I get laundry detergent that
works decently well and that's not I'm
not saying that P&G goes gets off scot
free but they stopped making Pringles
they stopped making Pringles yeah
Oh interesting yeah they sold it off
somebody else makes him though
interesting an interesting Nestle sold
its confectionary business here in the
United States to Ferrero Rocher for 2.8
billion dollars yeah yeah now the bad
news is that Nestle is increasing sales
of all of its CPG goods around the world
particularly in the poorest sections of
Brazil CPG consumer packaged goods right
and particularly of what do you know
which goods that yeah everything with
sugar in it with sugar in it yeah yeah
so they're the the fact is a lot of
companies know they've got a problem
they see the writing on the wall and
they're trying to do something without
actually admitting fault
because if they admit fault then the
lawsuits come that whole BS that
happened with the taking fat a fat-free
foods instead of going that was such a
crappy crappy tangent away from what's
actually important well in fact we know
because we have the paper trail that
they knew what they were doing they made
a conscious decision the food industry
made a conscious decision back in the
mid 60s
that number one they could deal with
this heart disease issue by subverting
the whole sugar heart disease question
and bringing up the LDL fat question
number two they could launch an entire
new line
of you know fat-free products which you
know expanded their reach and they could
argue that you could eat whatever you
wanted and all of that was propaganda
every single thing because they knew and
we know they knew because my colleagues
at UCSF Kristin Karns Laura Schmidt and
Stan glance found the paper trail and we
now at UCSF have the food industry
documents archive yeah 300 thousand
pages of food industry email documents
that said that basically tell us what
the food industry was thinking just like
we have the tobacco yeah documents
archive we now have the food documents
archive and your entire listenership and
viewership should look go online IDL
UCSF dot edu and you can look it up
yourself and you can actually do your
own research and publish your own papers
using the tobacco the tobacco and the
food industry's own words mm-hmm
and this we've seen this now happen with
the tobacco industry
where there was a massive amount of
propaganda that was pushed out even
though they knew the truth that nicotine
was addictive and they continued putting
other crappy chemicals inside of those
freedom sticks yep even [ __ ] worse
and then then there's the process of
revealing that crap and that that that
has been going on and then finally now
it's not in restaurants it's not in
planes it's not in etc so the kids can't
can't market it towards kids well when
are you gonna be able to not market
Snickers bars and Coca Cola's towards
kids what is this open happiness
campaign that is again that's again it
was open pleasure that would be funny
cuz it be true it would be true but it's
not that's not what they're marketing
you know we've got open happiness we got
a happy meal we got happy hour we you
know it's cetera so the point is they
want you
you think you can buy happiness and it
is true you can buy pleasure you can buy
dopamine no question there but you
cannot buy happiness what we've learned
is because of the relationship in the
brain between dopamine and serotonin
because of how the neuroscience of these
two neuronal systems work and because of
the overlay of a third neural system the
stress fear memory cortisol in half way
and how it works
to actually up your dopamine and down
your serotonin basically the more
pleasure you seek the more unhappy you
get and that's what we're seeing and
this explains how we can have a
simultaneous addiction crisis and
depression crisis because we have a
pleasure crisis and the pleasures going
both towards the addictions as well as
the depressions well the the the
increased dopamine is leading to a
decrease serotonin serotonin receptor
thereby reducing serotonin signal
transduction and making people anxious
and miserable and now you've got a yeah
I wanna explosion instead all of these
things actually tie to the same basic
precepts and as long as you don't
understand the problem you are
subservient to it yeah yeah this is a
whole education for children I hope I
hope that the these there's sort of
grassroots things that we're saying you
know dr. Braam Bronner's they're like
all is one or all are one and they're
there they make a bunch of different
things including things like dish soaps
and body soaps and their materials are
completely sustainable and biodegradable
not anyway there's a big push for
different food companies to have you
know one or two ingredients in their
food or the soaps have one or two
ingredients well indeed look the closer
we can get to real food the better off
we will all be and if you only have one
or two ingredients then the chances are
it's closer to real food
yeah processed food tends to have many
many ingredients you know there's an old
saying if the number of ingredients on
the package is 5 or greater you know
don't buy it because that means it's
ultra processed and we now have the data
that shows that ultra processed food is
the driver the driver of metabolic
syndrome and the cancer and we're
starting to collect the data that says
that it's also the driver of dementia
yeah that's crazy because dementia is
now becoming its ranking with cancer as
the absolute horrific things that are
taking human humans down and so and
there's actually costs more it costs
more dementia costs more than cancer
that's yeah and people are unable to
have happy times with their families and
their friends and even just yeah yeah so
that's terrific and if if the if if when
we swim upstream and we see the
corruption of the food systems and the
corruption of the technology systems and
the corruption of everything that's
coming down with pleasure pleasure
pleasure pleasure and we give a big fat
middle finger up to that that pled those
pleasure systems and we build from the
grassroots we build the humane text
ethical design systems that we build the
the food systems that are only one or
two ingredients and we propagate those
around the world that'll be a good way
to lead by example for children
therefore finally coming to a dam
solution with this well let's talk about
children here for a minute
children are particularly vulnerable now
we know they're vulnerable the question
is why are they vulnerable
and when are they vulnerable if you look
at childhood and adolescence there is
more mental health prevalence during
those years than there is at any other
time whether it be impulsivity disorders
whether it be depression whether it be
schizophrenia you added up these the
years of pre-pubertal the late puberty
pubertal and puberty are hotbeds of
mental health disorders and the question
is why and the answer is this area of
the brain right here three rounds a
quarter right behind your forehead it's
called the prefrontal cortex it is the
part of your brain that it makes you
human
it is the part of your brain that no
other species on the planet has it is
the part of your brain that is the most
developed but because it's the last part
of the brain to have developed
evolutionarily there's also the last
part of the brain to develop
antigenically in any one given person
you know so you don't develop your
prefrontal cortex until puberty begins
and you don't finish developing it until
puberty is over about age 25 in that
period from say 12 to 25 you are laying
down myelin mm-hmm the fatty sheath that
basically coats all neurons and that
myelin ization does not finish until age
25 and it is because your prefrontal
cortex is so rudimentary so primitive
and so susceptible to damage during
those years that all of these diseases
are so prevalent it's also why insurance
companies jack up the rates
on adolescents and young adults is
because they all think they're immortal
it's why the Armed Forces recruit 18
year olds because they think they're
immortal after age 25 people realize oh
my god you know what did I do
so this is a particularly vulnerable
time because of this process of violin
ization now I'm gonna give you a way to
think about this you have a battery and
you have two wires one wire is bare and
the other one has a plastic insulation
over and the battery is a strong battery
you put the bare wire over it and you
put the insulated wire over which of
those two wires is going to short out
first the one without the conductivity
the one without the insulation
insulation the bare wire yeah okay so it
turns out dopamine this excitatory
neurotransmitter it excites the next
neuron yeah and neurons like to be
excited that's why they have receptors
but neurons like to be tickled not
bludgeoned chronic over stimulation of
any neuron will lead to neuronal cell
death now if that neuron happens to be
myelinated it's a lot harder to kill him
mm-hmm
but bare neurons unmyelinated neurons
they're easy to kill and guess what that
prefrontal cortex all through
adolescence its unmyelinated it's easy
to kill and so there are a lot of toxins
there are a lot of drugs including by
the way marijuana which kill that neuron
so the question is what happens if you
kill your prefrontal cortex while you're
an adolescent
ain't good yeah if you fall susceptible
from these years of 12 to 25 as your
neural architecture is forming and you
get manipulated through these
pleasure-seeking systems for food or for
processed foods sugars technology
addictions lack of sleep lack of sleeps
the the stat you had was that it graders
that had their phones in their butt
charging in their bedrooms slept 28
minutes less this is what you are
describing a couple minutes ago this
each nerve cells they like to be excited
a lot of your myelin sheath here gets
formed in your adolescent years right
and that nerves like to be excited and
that's awesome because you know
neurotransmitters get to come they get
to communicate between areas of the
brain but when you get so addicted to
pleasure pleasure pleasure
you were teaching us that the neurons
actually they-they-they
in order to as a defense mechanism it
turns off its excitatory abilities
through other neurons well what it does
what it does yeah Erol and almost almost
almost yeah please
so neurons like to be excited but they
don't like to die they don't want to die
so what they have is they have a plan B
they have a self defense mechanism
chronic over stimulation of any neuron
will lead to neuronal cell death but
there's a plan B what they do is they
down regulate the number of receptors so
that there's less likelihood that any
given dopamine molecule will find the
dopamine receptor to bind to thereby
reducing the game reducing the amplitude
here right exactly on those dendrites
yep right there and so what does that
mean in human terms means you get a hit
you get a rush receptors go down next
time you need a bigger hit you get the
same rush because there are fewer
receptors and receptors go down and then
you do bigger hit a bigger hit bigger
until finally need a huge hit to get
nothing that phenomena is called
tolerance yeah and then when the neurons
actually do start to die which will
happen in the chronic overstimulation
state particularly in the bare wire
state when those neurons start to die
that's called addiction and that's why
teenagers are most susceptible to
addiction so the more pleasure they seek
the more unhappy they get and the
problem is once those neurons are dead
they ain't coming back because central
nervous system neurons don't reproduce
so you're basically at low ebb for the
rest of your life
camera salute dawn event this can rely
on the neurogenesis of sorts for there
are specific areas of the brain that
have neurogenesis the nucleus accumbens
like the hippocampus as long as your
cortisol levels are low interesting yeah
if your cortisol levels are high forget
about I get about it okay
and also the olfactory system has
neurogenesis but the number of areas of
the brain that have reproducing neurons
are extraordinarily few and far between
and the reward system is not one of them
interesting so the goal is to protect
your reward system so you can experience
pleasure I'm is the more pleasure you
look for the less you'll be able to
experience later and we're not allowing
our children any semblance of figuring
this out for themselves because we're
handing them an iPad at age 12 months
yeah yeah babysitter as you called it
the portable babysitter and then then
when you get all these as a pediatric
endocrinologist when you go and you see
these kids that you that you're dealing
with in the clinics the kids are coming
in with a deteriorated sense of
imagination indeed so Piaget
famous child psychologist of the 20th
century famously said play is the work
of the child
yeah that's the child's job I add to
that boredom is the opportunity of the
child yeah there's no play without
boredom because that's how the child
decides to work that gives the child an
impetus to do so yeah if you take that
away by handing them a screen you're
actually inhibiting their ability to
create you're inhibiting their
imagination and not only that but they
will never figure out how to self-soothe
they will never figure out how to be
alone sherry Turkle famous media watcher
at MIT coined the famous phrase if we
don't teach our children how to be alone
they will always be lonely mm-hmm and
guess what when you're lonely you go for
pleasure-seeking you sure do we have an
entire generation of lonely people yeah
and then we're told by Facebook oh we'll
connect you
oh no you won't Facebook is not
connection Facebook is connectivity
without connection you cannot have
connection with anonymous doesn't exist
and the reason is because connection
like you and I are doing right now is
eye-to-eye face-to-face which does not
occur at a digital keyboard why does
that matter
why do you and I have to have an
eye-to-eye in order to have connection
because we have a set of neurons in the
back of our head in the occipital lobe
they're called mirror neurons you can
record from them they're you know
they're their own distinct entity and
what they're do we walk down the street
see someone's smiling you tend to smile
back yeah what you what those neurons
are doing is they are reading the facial
expression of the person you are talking
to in real time yeah so as you're
sitting there you know with this you
know
satisfied look on your face I'm reading
that okay and you're watching me be
quite vehement and we're a Malaysian
connect we are feels really good it
feels like indeed the souls are dancing
right and it feels amazing and you can't
get this from the comment section No and
you certainly can't get it from the
anonymous section so I'm reading your
facial expressions in real-time and I am
translating your emotion into my own and
that has a name it's called empathy and
if you can't do it you're a psychopath
so we're not allowing kids to be
empathic yeah we're basically making
them do their homework on an iPad they
used to get together in groups now they
get together in groups on the internet
so they can sit in their own room rather
than across the table from each other we
are actually inhibiting their growth
this is not okay wow it's so bran go
ahead yeah you come in yeah you have
yeah I just have my friend Susan is
watching she thinks you're amazing
person they're talking nice well I've
been doing on the foul talk to Susan
Susan Ruger from Maine she's watching it
thanks for watching Susan ship will be
shout out shout out to people that can
tap into what you know Rob he was here
saying so
kid let's let's come let's come back to
this to the status as when when when
you're when you're speaking about this
I'm feeling you I'm looking at your eyes
I'm seeing your eyebrows and your lips
the way you smile the wrinkles the
wrinkles yeah look at my ring you know
we're in friends and more wrinkles it's
you look fantastic by the way doc when
you said you were 72 years old I'm like
oh my god he be second I'll do you in
2029 at 29 and yeah it definitely looks
good but every single one of these
nuances to a facial expression
it's a moment-to-moment processing just
like the computer is processing moment
to moment what you are asking it to do I
am processing moments moment someone's
expressions the better we can get at
understanding different emotional states
and connecting with people on the
deepest emotional basis the stronger we
will have our humane ties to each other
indeed so let me give you two thoughts
on this Paul Ekman famous psychologist
from UC Berkeley went to Papua New
Guinea many many years ago never seen a
white person they had the exact same
facial expressions for the same emotions
that we did yeah they didn't know us
yeah yeah but they happiness same facial
motion frowning you know meant the same
thing no matter where you went on the
planet we're talking hundreds of
thousands of years of evolutionary date
dim welcome because it preceded language
preceded language that's right preceded
language that's right thank you Ron yeah
literally preceding language we could go
we could still communicate pre grunts
and moans and we were still I - I facial
expression that's right yeah okay so
that exists the problem is we're
destroying it
number two what was number two oh yeah
can you cut that um number two religion
religion is a great microcosm for this
whole issue so there are 4,200 religions
on the planet 4,200 4,200 whoa so why
are there 4,200 because the number 42 is
awesome I'm not sure if that's why
because of Jackie Robinson maybe I don't
but anyway there are 4,200 religions on
the planet they all share one thing in
common a meeting place for face-to-face
interaction correct interesting where
you worship together together yes okay
there's no religion without some place
together
no interesting once the pastor or the
rabbi or the Imam or whoever it is you
know opens their mouth okay that's
dopamine okay but that meeting place
that's serotonin yeah okay that's the
ethereal feeling that you get when
you're there with so many other people
celebrating something that is
spiritually transcends humans indeed
okay and it's also contributing to
something larger than yourself which is
also a method for generating serotonin
so there are four methods that I know of
that up your serotonin tamp down your
dopamine lower your cortisol called the
four C's called the four C's and they're
clinically proven to work evidence-based
and your money back money-back guarantee
but since none of them cost anything
yeah forget forget about the refund this
that's right all free and they're all
things your mother told you yeah okay
but we forgot mother taught the mother
is hundreds of thousands of years ago
and we have forgotten it in
last fifty years yeah all four of them
first connect like we've talked about
number to contribute to something bigger
than yourself
so contributing to your IRA is not
contributing okay
passing along small amounts of micro
financing to artists and entrepreneurs
and people around the world contributing
through going out and spending a day
just helping people that need it the
assistance and help
that creates sense of empathy connection
between people volunteerism altruism
philanthropy all you listening out there
okay that's a contribution third cope
cope is not with pleasure not with
pleasure
no no coping against pleasure if
anything it's the opposite three things
sleep mindfulness exercise those are
great now sleep is going away 35% of
Americans get less than seven hours of
sleep per night and 23% are clinical
insomniac s-- damn and what that does is
it fries your prefrontal cortex and what
that does is it allows reward and
dopamine to go great guns puts your
serotonin in the sewer and your cortisol
goes haywire you aware of Matt Walker's
why we sleep yeah yeah because there's a
it's a whole information integration
process from the previous day that you
have to go through the period of sleep I
can't believe it thirty five percent are
going flat for seven hours yes it's
because we're getting jammed down our
throats this notion of needing to
needing to do everything possible to
make some sort of a the impacting the
world has now become pleasure-seeking
that I need the watches and I need the
cars and I need the houses and I need
the girls and the boys and the people
that's that's that's so dumb that's
gonna run
the ground so I'm gonna tell you that
they're - they're actually two phenomena
going on underneath there one if you're
missing out so you stay up and the other
is the blue light the blue light
phenomenon the blue light phenomena
emitting melatonin exactly and that's
why kids who sleep with their cell
phones in their rooms get twenty eight
minutes less per night not because
they're on them but because of the blue
light so the fourth C the fourth C is
cook yep so there are three items three
nutrients if you will that play a role
in this pleasure happiness story the
more you cook the less you can be taken
advantage of by the corruption of course
systems well of course because you're
making real food so there are three
items one is tryptophane tryptophane is
the precursor of serotonin it is the
rarest amino acid on the planet
interesting okay usually find it in eggs
poultry fish interesting tryptophan
those are not exactly processed food
number two omega-3 fatty acids you have
to get healthy this is very important
you have to get like cage free chickens
or she'll have or may have higher
tryptophan yes AFI tryptophan and lower
branch chain amino acids which actually
contribute to dopamine self-interested
India and also metabolic syndrome so
omega-3 fatty acids which are
anti-inflammatory and increased
serotonin neurotransmission
and finally fructose the sweet molecule
and sugar which ups you dopamine and
downs your serotonin so what you want is
a high tryptophane high omega-3 low
fructose diet yeah that's called real
food and you can supplement omega-3
quite easily if you buy the right stuff
stuff yeah there's a lot of omega-3s
that are actually omega-3 omega-6
combinations and that's not good not as
good you want just Omega Omega 3s and
that gets expensive so you have to and
you have to look at the label know that
whether it and the easiest way to know
is whether it's farm-raised fish oil or
wild fish along while you want while not
farm
that's right yeah that costs more that
costs more so in Kirkland will get you
build empathy build relationships
between families so cooking a meal for
yourself your family friends you get
connection you get contribution you get
coping because cooking is mindful you
got to actually pay attention okay and
finally the cooking itself so shout out
to Michael Pollan for pushing cooking as
well absolutely humanity wanting
absolutely and you know everything
Michael said I agree with except for one
he said seven famous words eat food not
too much mostly plants and you disagree
with the last part I think I can say it
better in three words huh
eat real food eat real food
because then not too much will take care
of itself because real food has fiber
and you give full and you get full and
also you're feeding your bacterial
microbiome right so he'd say mostly
plants that'll get you there - yeah yeah
what I think is that the not too much
and the mostly plants to take care of
itself if you're eating it if you need
real food now there are a whole bunch of
people who do not believe in the vegan
diet which is the mostly plants you know
this whole you know whole food
plant-based business there's some people
that are I don't go neveress yeah yeah I
don't care as long as it's real is your
point correct real yeah Crowley the
carnivores can live with the grain mines
and the plant right you CF I don't care
if you're a vegan or you're a ketogenic
I don't care I really don't care
okay real food yeah what do they have in
common they would seem to be completely
diametrically opposite and the answer is
they have two things in common no
fructose low sugar high fiber high fiber
yeah low sugar high side
when you when you this is now become
more and more of a famous example but
when you down a soda it goes directly
into digital fiber there's no final
price the sugar lots of sugar and nofa
but then when you eat a handful of
almonds there's a lot of fiber and so
then it's slow release I'll leave it
I'll even give you a fruit app so yeah I
mean fruit uh sugar there's fiber but
the fiber content you have an apple is
enormous and so when you consume the
sugar with the fiber called an apple
what you're doing is you're setting up a
gel on the inside of your intestine the
soluble and insoluble fiber the inside
of a fiber forms a latticework of the
gel kind of like the hair catcher on
your bathtub drain yeah and then the
soluble fiber globular fiber plugs the
holes in that lattice work and you form
an impenetrable barrier you form a
secondary barrier on the inside you do
add them reducing the rate of absorption
thus keeping your liver healthy so you
don't get metabolic syndrome and because
you didn't absorb it early it gets
transferred further down the intestine
to the jejunum where the bacteria are
and then the bacteria chew it up for
their purposes so you're feeding your
bacteria so even though you've consumed
it even though it passed your lips it
didn't pass your intestine therefore you
ate it but you didn't get it but your
bacteria did so you improved your gut
health and you improved your liver
health by preventing the tsunami of all
of these macronutrients hitting your
liver all at once you solve both
problems at once with real food and it
doesn't matter all the other stuff is
window dressing whether it's you know
straight vegetables or whether it's you
know meat containing or not so that's
where the two factions have to basically
understand that they can peacefully
coexist with the other one yeah yeah
okay what they can't code this with is
processed food yeah
that's rather this is so fascinating and
I would love for the conversation to
continue onward and actually we'd love
to have you back on the show in 2019 and
early in the year and we can start
talking about these topics and even more
depth but also just building out the
first principles frameworks for chill
for for adults and for their children
something as simple as the complete ban
of sugary soft drinks will start and
like you said getting the adequate
amount of sleep getting exercise in not
having the phone's around at at late
times in the night cooking more at home
the solutions that that you've been
listening I've been just so simple and
we just got to make them habits well
they're not simple they're not simple at
all look at technology technology is
simple but if you know fixing it to be
useful and a tool rather than an
entertainment yeah it's not simple yeah
and that's where Tristan Harris and
Roger McNamee in the Center for Humane
Technology come in we need developers to
agree and adhere to first principles
first do no harm okay fact matter is I'm
a physician I had to take an oath first
do no harm
developers first do no harm and right
now you're doing a whole bunch of harm
yeah that's that's a very profound
statement because with that if the
developers that are building out the the
bioengineering and neuro engineering and
artificial intelligence engineering
systems are they did that we don't have
a solid platform of ethicists and
philosophers that are co-working with
them that we're gonna have some serious
geopolitical pressures that occur
already have already have so what
happened in 2016 election yeah and
that's understandable because propaganda
and its influence
it's the dopamine response curve it's a
u-shaped curve it's a bell-shaped curve
a bell curve bell-shaped curve it's not
a straight up-and-down curve it's a
bell-shaped curve if you're to the left
of optimal you're lethargic if you're to
the right of optimal you're irritable
what the Russians did was they took all
the lethargic people and made a Mirabal
hmm by upping their dopamine mmm they'll
do it again in a in a way to be robust
and AM and even just being not being
fragile to that being anti fragile to
the manipulation of propaganda is to to
be fine more Zen fine more nuance don't
um be focused so much on these
consumptive emotive echo chambers of
crap that we see so much of right yeah
be alone be alone don't be lonely don't
be lonely yeah yeah I'm knowing how to
be alone or I'm so important we've we've
been talking about that a lot with
meditation and it's like you said
mindfulness and and yeah and there's so
much pleasure-seeking that occurs when
we are when we can't when we don't know
how to be alone that's right yeah I feel
so much more awakened and I hope you
guys do too I want to I want to just ask
you just a couple quick questions that
we like asking on the show do you think
that we're alone in the cosmos I think
we will find out we are not alone but I
don't think we're gonna find it out soon
okay and then do you think we're in a
simulation
[Laughter]
I think some people are in a simulation
what why do I don't think I am
except that I'm on simulation right now
but I don't think I think that my life
has had enormous meaning and I know that
the day I die I won't wonder what the
hell I did with it if you don't know
what the hell you did with it then
you're in a simulation that was so good
if so it's paraphrase if you have found
meaning in your day-to-day journey and
life you are not in a simulation but if
you haven't found a meaning in your life
until your deathbed you are for sure in
a simulation that's gonna be that's
pretty interesting and there's there's a
YouTube internet cartoon it's about five
minutes long and everyone should watch
it it's called happiness look it up
which which one which one is it how long
is it you know it's about five minutes
five minutes
it's called happiness it's the rat race
and it's wonder oh I think I I think I
need to cut for about short-film years
ago putz that sounds right yes short
film by Steve cuts that's the one
it's brilliant interesting absolutely if
you've never seen it it's absolutely
Ramblers presence absolutely
so we'll you know you guys can watch
this I just wanted to at least pull it
up oh this one yeah this one's so good
best it's so so so brilliant so
brilliant so you you know this seven
point seven billion people now on the
planet crazy come stat that it took two
hundred thousand years to get a billion
people and now over the last two hundred
years we've gotten six billion six and
half billion more we have a lot of work
to do to make sure that we can't have
the prop
ganda come in and take advantage of
people and finding meaning in life
through the through society is so damn
important
and we can talk about that more next
time we've so much to talk about we
should we should schedule another
session to talk about the tragedy of the
Commons yeah yeah because that's what we
have yeah if you're if you're not
thinking differently then
Copernicus is one of my favorites and
this is you will fall into the masses
and the masses don't know the truth
truth comes from the process of finding
something meaningful in your life and
pursuing that and usually if you follow
against the Commons you can find
something as a free thinker that is
really impactful for them no one can
tell you the truth mmm well that's
interesting I like that I like that yeah
you have to figure the truth out you for
some thought for yourself you can for
sure have better parents and better
community and better friends around you
to help make it easier for you to find
that strip the truth I agreed that
because if you live in a place that has
the corrupt greed and the tentacles of
corruption it'll be much more difficult
but okay um and then last question is
what do you think is the most beautiful
thing in the world
whoa oh my kids why do you say that
because they are
cuz they're me here comes the ego the
ego yo Robert you're not you're this
lifelogging for itself what are you
talking about doc hey let's shout out to
Kai Faust who's been watching that oh
sorry to type on commenting high was
also out of the social media and
attention economy event shout out to Kai
thanks for the support much love for you
thanks for commenting as well and anyone
else to shout out Ron Susan Rooker yeah
we shout it out Susan yeah okay cool
cool I am blessed to know you and we're
blessed to have you and I'm an advisor I
thank you and I love how like you said
at the end of the show that you know
that when you pass you know that like
damn I lived it I knew what I needed to
done I did that that's so cool yeah if
we can have more you know more children
birth into the world knowing that find
that meaning and do it and you will have
no regrets I love it that's it
probabilistic such a pleasure but just
so much for coming onto the show my
pleasure thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we would love
to hear from you in the comments below
let us know what you thought also go and
check out Rob's links below the hacking
of the American mind his recent book
also follow Rob on Twitter also go and
build the future go manifest your
destiny into the world everyone
much love to you much love to Ron for
producing and directing we will see you
soon peace
[Applause]
you
[Music]